one of my favorite quotes if it's worth
doing it's worth doing well the reason
it's so important in my opinion is not
the way that most people think of it
most people think of that as oh you
should do a good job but it's actually
more important when you think about it
in reverse which is that most things
aren't worth doing what that means is
that you only have a limited bandwidth
of time and energy that you can allocate
to doing anything well if you want to
get the most leverage all of us have the
same number of hours every day but some
people move significantly faster and
it's because they do fewer things better
rather than trying to do everything well
and in so doing do nothing